what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be talking
about the strongest pillar Guillaume a
himself in the last video I'd said I'd
make this one if we got 5,000 likes and
we did so as promised here I am with the
newest how strong is video if we can get
5,000 likes again I will start in the
next one ASAP as always you can vote for
what that video is going to be via
Instagram stories make sure you're
following us on instagram at anime out
drawer because we regularly have these
votes over there if you haven't be sure
to subscribe it's important ring that
notification bell because if you don't
you won't get notified when you videos
come out there will be manga spoilers in
this video because we are going to be
looking at all of the evidence available
in order to figure out exactly how
strong kill made the strongest pillar
really is now without further ado let's
jump into it it may seem random to say
but one of the reasons that I like Gil
made the blind gentle giant is that he's
considerably older than time zero he's
actually 27 years old which is actually
older than me that means that he has a
lot more experience as well it's also
interesting that he cries so much even
though he's so strong and can kick so
much demon but his backstory is no less
tragic than that of the others in within
it we see the beginning of Gil Mays
power long ago he raised and protected
some orphan children in a temple their
collective lack of blood connections
actually connected them and help them
bond you may raise them all as if they
were his family he wanted to protect
them forever but one kid disobeyed the
temple rules and ran into a demon in
order to save himself the kids sold out
Gil Mei and the other eight kids at the
temple he put out the wisteria incense
aka demon repellent and the demons were
free to attack the demon killed four
kids immediately although Gil may wanted
to protect the other four three kids
didn't listen to him he explains that he
didn't eat a lot then he was skinny and
weak and even his voice was soft so he
couldn't shout loudly on top of that
because he was blind the kids didn't
trust that he could say that only the
youngest child Scio listened and stayed
the others were quickly killed but Gil
Mei was determined to protect sale at
all costs even though he's extremely
gentle by nature Gil may was ready to
fight punching
living things felt terrible he felt so
disgusted with himself for the first
time ever he used his fists with full
force and discovered that he had a
frightening amount of power it was
during this first battle that he got the
scar over his forehead if he was never
attacked by that demon
Yomi would have lived his entire life
not knowing he was actually strong this
guy who loves violence punched the
demons head again and again until the
Sun came up I don't know if there's a
more epic first demon encounter than
that it was a horrible situation but at
least he had protected saya
yet somehow saya turned on him despite
everything he did for her she was young
scared and confused and when people came
to help her she told them that Gil Mei
was a monster she told them that he
killed everyone
Yomi is one saving grace was that he
protected scio
he wanted her to be thankful but it
wasn't meant to be the person he saved
blamed him for everything
Yomi was imprisoned and charged with
murder he was going to be executed but
luckily Oya kata sama saved him from
there he went on to become the strongest
pillar when their training under him he
knows he can't help but notice how
awesome Gil may AKA ball-ball old guy is
in Oskie who has amazing animal-like
intuition says that yo Mei gave him
chills ever since the first time he met
him he knows K says that there is no
doubt about it
Chioma is the strongest demon hunter and
then tangier agrees with him saying he
figured that as well tonzura says he's
the only one with a different smell
Yomi is so strong that when tundra says
- sunny - maybe he can also become that
strong zatia tells him that there's no
chance
according to Sonny to kill me is insane
he's as big as a bear and as a result he
is born with more strength than smaller
guys obviously size doesn't matter that
much in anime and manga yo Deecee the
strongest team you say in history could
still have defeated yo may even as an
old man but it's still interesting to
note how others experienced Gil mais
immense strength now let's fast forward
to kiyomi's most important fight to date
the fighting gets up removal on Coco she
bowed the strongest upper moon can help
us to get a sense of Gilmer's power as
soon as Coco's she will seize Guillaume
a he comments that Yomi has a perfect
physical form and that he developed it
to the utmost
Goku she will calm is that it's been
three
years since he's seen someone so
talented and strong yo may unlike most
of the other demon slayers doesn't use a
sword to battle he uses a chain with a
giant spike ball on one end of it and an
axe on the other as we see against Coco
chibok yo me is extremely skilled and he
can release both of these weapons at his
opponent at the same time the chain is
so strong the purity of all the iron is
so extremely high that even Kakashi
bowed the greatest upper moon cannot
hope to cut through it with his blade
kuku she will claims the iron that has
absorbed that much sunlight hadn't even
been discovered in the Sengoku period
when sword smithing was at its peak
so Kiyomi has an extraordinary weapon to
go with his extraordinary strength
despite how no one else could hope to
fight one-on-one against Goku she bow
Joey does pretty well for a while he
dodges a number of Coco she bows attacks
kakushi bo says that Yomi is heavily
built and has the strength to wield his
extremely heavy weapon as if it was an
extension of his body with so much
lightness and agility Coco Shiba says
that it's nothing short of unbelievable
such a compliment from the strongest
upper moon further speaks to Guillaume a
strength you may even man just to break
oku she bowls blade although it quickly
regenerates all this happens before Gil
may even gets fully serious he goes on
to manifest his Demon Slayer mark which
drastically increases his impressive
power even further when Coco Chabot says
that the mark means Gil Mei will die
soon Gil may cool as a rock is not fazed
at all he says that for all demon
Slayers there is no guarantee that you
will live to tomorrow
Yomi asks why would he cling to life at
this point and says that no one becomes
a pillar with such half-hearted
determination the fact that Yomi is
ready to die at any point doesn't only
make him cool it also makes him strong
because fears don't cloud his judgment
or slow him down
Yomi is also skilled enough to sense
when Kakashi bow lies to him he says
that there was an exception a person who
didn't die from the mark and he's right
that person was the breath of the Sun
user and strong as Demon Slayer in
history you're Ichi even though it's not
physical this small psychological
victory against the centuries-old upper
moon further illustrates how talented
Yomi is there's much more to him than
just being physically talent
eventually Sunday me jumps into the
fight but it's insane that Yomi could
last as long as he did against Coco she
bow without receiving any serious
injuries we get even more of a sense of
how ahead of the other pillars Gil me is
when the other pillars joined the battle
again Sunday me is arguably the second
strongest pillar and yet the gap between
him and yo mate is obvious it gets an
especially powerful attack yo may not
only defense himself but even man just
to use his chain to alter the angle of
the attack so that son of me wouldn't
lose both of his arms
in short Yomi can not only fight against
Goku she bow he can even save son of me
in the process
sodomy notices that the more damage he
takes the more he holds Geo may back at
one point Sanne me even tells gilma to
forget about him but luckily mu Ichiro
saves him during the fight Yomi gets
access to the see-through world even
though he can't see he can sense it only
the most advanced fighters like Kakashi
Bowyer Ichi Tanja and so on have gained
access to this world showing that yo may
truly deserves to be considered among
the strongest fighters ever it is then
Gil made that turns a tide of the match
yes he has held from Muay to know inside
of me but Gil me is the one that manages
to throw a ball from his rosary and hit
the upper moon's hand without him
noticing in time
it throws Kakashi bow off and allows
gilma to take out the demons right arm
with his big iron ball now keep in mind
if Coco Shiba wasn't a demon this will
have been a big blow against him as it
would be for any swordsman Coco she bow
has to use demon powers to heal which is
a blow to his samurais pride then mu
Ichiro gets him with his blade that
eventually turns red ganya helps and
eventually Gil me hits Coco she bows
head with his spiked ball and what's
enemies help both of their weapons turn
red and they succeed in knocking off
Goku she bows head coach evil cannot
help but think that Gil may speed up
growth is comparable to a demon he moves
in ways that surpasses limit the fact
that Gil Mays weapon turned red is also
significant red is undoubtedly the most
powerful color it was the same color
that your each his blade was and he was
the strongest demon slayer who used the
strongest breath
Yomi was already strong but during this
fight he manifested the mark gain access
to the see-through world and his weapon
turned red those are huge advancements
unlike green Goku who
a set was near his limit Yomi seems to
keep surpassing his limit despite the
fact that he's already the strongest
pillar by the time Fukushima eventually
disintegrates for good
he has mortally wounded Moo Ichiro in
Kenya sunny is badly wounded it has lost
consciousness but gilma is up and about
he's ready to move on immediately to
fight moves on this is the caliber of
fighter Gil Mei is he had help from the
other pillars and ganya but it's
significant that Coco's evil didn't
manage to significantly hurt him even
when they fought one-on-one
he continued to grow quickly during that
match and even managed to save son of me
and turned the tide of the match after
he acts as the seed through world would
I say he's stronger than up her moon one
no he needed help and up her moon one
almost succeeding growing back his head
if he didn't give up the will to fight
he would have been invincible aka
unkillable except through sunlight
however now I do believe that Gil me is
more powerful than the other upper moons
were except potentially aquas after he
briefly managed to regrow his head but
he also ended up destroying himself like
ogre sebum Yomi as a mal should be
considered to be weaker than demons who
have attained in its ability like Mulan
especially if they are fighting in an
area with no Sun nevertheless I think he
could have defeated upper moon too in a
one-on-one fight at this point which is
saying a lot
the most exciting thing is that Gil may
still seems to have a lot of room to
grow and if you're teaching could avoid
the Demon Slayer markers it's possible
that Gil Mei will be able to avoid it
too I can't wait to see how strong Gil
may gets and I have no doubt that he
will play a vital role during the fight
against Mouzon and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you liked it make sure to
smash that like button to let me know
remember as soon as we hit 5,000 likes
I'll get started on the next vid ASAP
and you can vote for who that video will
be about on instagram at anime uproar
I'll put the link in the description and
in a pin comment remember to follow us
there so you can help decide what videos
I make in the future if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is very
important hit that notification bell or
else you will not know when the next
video comes out thanks again for
everything and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]